[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy recibimos a huelva heart haití white
y una sobreviviente del galaxy no ese es
de hecho el título del libro que acaba
de escribir y de publicar hoy con gula
usted se refiere por supuesto a sus
campos de internamiento que hay por
decenas en la región de xinjiang en
china en los cuales usted estuvo
detenida hasta su liberación hace ya un
año y medio y donde todavía están
detenidos cientos de miles tal vez
millones de uigures esa minoría
musulmana en su mayoría musulmana a la
cual usted pertenece su historia también
es dramática e inédita es necesario
saber que usted vivía en francia desde
hacía más de 15 años pero su vida dio un
vuelco estamos en noviembre de 2016 y en
ese momento usted recibe una llamada al
otro lado del teléfono le habla a su
antiguo empleador que está radicado en
china en xinjiang que le pide el en ese
momento
me pide que vaya a china a solicitar mi
jubilación anticipada le pregunto si
puedo hacerlo a través de un poder y mi
colega me dice que no
diariamente debo ir hasta allá y que
debo hacerlo yo misma entonces compré
unos pasajes de ida y vuelta para una
estadía de dos semanas y nunca me
imaginé que me separaría de mi familia y
de mi libertad durante tres años
justamente usted piensa que utilizaron a
este empleador para ponerle una trampa
para obligarla a regresar a xinjiang en
ese momento cuando usted llega a su
antigua empresa es detenida de inmediato
por la policía de que se le acusa de que
se tratan las preguntas que me muestran
una foto de mi hija en una manifestación
con la bandera de turkestán oriental me
lanzaron la foto a la cara una
manifestación que se llevó a cabo en
parís
y me acusaron de ser la madre de una
terrorista
y también de ser la mujer de un
terrorista en retrospectiva creo que
querían vengarse de mi marido porque en
2012 y en 2014 cuando fui a china con mi
marido el servicio de seguridad chino le
había pedido que fuera un espía de la
comunidad uigur en francia mi marido se
negó y creo que eso era una trampa
problema
en ese momento la liberan pero le
confiscan su pasaporte y un mes después
cuando usted llega a recogerlo la
arrestan inmediatamente y esta vez la
llevan a una cárcel no se trata todavía
de los campos de reeducación de xinjiang
pero las condiciones en la cárcel son
particularmente atroces no nos las
podría describir
las condiciones son extremadamente malas
en esas casas de detención todas las
mujeres tienen los pies encadenados en
una celda para nueve o diez somos hasta
40 todos los días nos llevan afuera
durante varias horas aunque hace hasta
menos 30 grados las luces de neón
blancas están prendidas las 24 horas del
día por la noche debemos hacer guardia
entonces dormimos muy mal son la
malnutrición siempre está presente y
tenemos ropa muy delgada
[Música]
de hecho creo saber que usted estuvo
literalmente encadena a su cama que pasó
le dijeron por qué y en qué condiciones
se hizo eso
me encadenaron a la cama durante 20 días
y les pregunté que había hecho si había
infringido el reglamento interno y me
dijeron que no sabían y que la orden
venía de las autoridades superiores
cuatro meses después la transfirieron
justamente a uno de esos campos de
reeducación que incluso le dijeron que
tenía la gracia de ir a un campo de
reeducación
los guardias hablan precisamente de
escuela en este momento usted pasa por
un lavado de cerebro con clases que
duran más de once horas diarias
que le enseñan en esas clases y en qué
condiciones
al principio realmente nos imaginábamos
una verdadera escuela y estábamos
bastante contentas estaban dv
pero después de llegar a este campo
realmente entendimos que no se trataba
para
de una escuela debíamos estar 11 horas
al día sentadas en clase tomando unos
cursos de derecho de chino y de historia
china
además de eso todos los días debemos
aprender cantos patrióticos todos los
viernes teníamos exámenes sobre los
cursos de la semana
además debíamos llevar un diario en el
cual debíamos escribir todo lo que se
nos cruzaba por la cabeza
pero desafortunadamente no podíamos
escribir lo que quisiéramos porque
nuestros tutores recogían el diario cada
dos o tres días lo re leía más entonces
estábamos obligadas a alabar al partido
político chino ya decir que estábamos
satisfechas de estar ahí
cuál es el perfil de esas detenidas son
todas figuras y sobre todo qué hicieron
entre comillas
[Música]
ahí sólo hay wilburys las razones de su
presencia allí son distintas
algunas están ahí porque llevan el velo
o porque tienen conocidos en el
extranjero o porque han viajado al
extranjero o también porque han
contestado las llamadas de las personas
que hacen parte de la lista negra y esa
gente ni siquiera saben quiénes son esas
personas y hay muchas que ni siquiera
saben por qué están ahí
bajar a haití como muchas otras mujeres
que salieron de esos campos de
reeducación usted habla en su libro de
esas inyecciones que recibió en varias
ocasiones sabe que contenían esas
jeringas
dos veces al año nos vacunaron decían
que eran vacunas contra la gripe pero
después de esas vacunas muchas mujeres
jóvenes dejaron de tener su menstruación
y vi a mujeres jóvenes de preocuparse
por su futuro pensando que ya no iban a
poder tener hijos
entonces en esa época empecé a sospechar
de esas vacunas pero no tenía pruebas en
ese momento como fue sólo hasta que
regrese a francia cuando supe que las
jóvenes mujeres uigures habían recibido
esterilización es en más
tomás en noviembre de 2018 usted fue
finalmente condenado a 7 años de cárcel
fue acusada de haber falsificado
documentos administrativos es el regreso
a la casa de la destrucción el regreso
al encadenamiento y al mismo tiempo una
niña su hija lucharía sin tregua por su
liberación
lumar usted estaba al tanto de esas
acciones y cree que eso contribuyó a su
liberación
en bogotá
y es que en esa época no sabía lo que mi
hija ni lo que francia estaban haciendo
pero cuando llegué a francia realmente
me di cuenta de que me consideraron como
una verdadera ciudadana francesa con un
expediente consular y de todas las
acciones que mi hija llevó a cabo
industrial del anime francés en agosto
de 2019 usted finalmente fue liberada
pero antes de eso la llevaron durante
varios meses a una residencia vigilada
donde paso por una especie de
acondicionamiento físico que ocurriría
en esa casa y que le dirían
estaba muy delgada no estaba ni siquiera
50 kilos entonces china pensó que si me
liberaba en ese estado eso no sería
bueno para su imagen y que todo lo que
le hacían pasar a los uigures saldría a
la luz entonces decidieron mejorar mi
condición física hacerme ganar peso y
esa fue la razón por la cual se ocuparon
de mí en ese apartamento
en su libro usted habla de genocidio una
palabra bastante fuerte para describir
la política llevada a cabo por el
gobierno chino en zhiliang porque
escogió esa palabra
en las casas de detención y en los
campos nosotros no podemos hablar
nuestro idioma los chinos nos están
haciendo asimilar su propia cultura sus
tradiciones
si quieren hacer desaparecer toda la
cultura y las tradiciones figures y
después conseguir que desaparezcan todos
los uigures también están los
matrimonios interétnicos una pareja de
uigures y dejan reciben ciento cincuenta
mil yuanes por parte del estado y hay
una verdadera propaganda sobre estos
matrimonios para animar a que haya más
durante las fiestas religiosas figures
los uigures ni siquiera pueden ir a las
mezquitas creo que todos estos elementos
pueden servir como prueba para decir que
hay un verdadero genocidio cultural
en xinjiang están todavía su hermana y
también su madre ha tenido noticias de
ellas desde su liberación y en
particular desde la publicación de este
libro la publicación se niega
desde que regresé llamo a mi familia una
vez a la semana con nuestras
conversaciones no duran mucho tiempo y
no puedo decirles cosas delicadas
simplemente me entero de las novedades
mi familia ni siquiera está al tanto de
la existencia de este libro
es tan bueno amsé patricia más hasta la
materia es producto
teme por ellas
al principio cuando empecé a escribir
este libro realmente estaba muy
preocupada porque aunque no había hecho
nada contra china de todas maneras me
robaron tres años de mi libertad
a mi familia a costos live entonces sí
china sería capaz de hacerle daño a mi
familia a causa de este libro pero
después de pensarlo no escribí nada
exagerado no mentí en este libro no
disfruté a las personas sobre escribir
la verdad y entonces ahora no tengo
miedo de nadie
will bajar haiti why y gracias por su
testimonio recuerdo el título de su
libro sobreviviente del gulag chino
editado por edición de cohete ahora
gracias a todos por habernos sintonizado
continúa la información en france 24
[Música]